let's do this clip dude holy [ __ ] man
oh my god i wanted to start the episode
with this this lady dude you know i used
to think this kind of [ __ ] was hilarious
and then i realized people are just got
brain problems
but here we go
[ __ ] i'm just trying to help you i'm
sorry but i don't need your help
yes you do [ __ ]
you do you do need my help sir they're
out of cbs
oh threw in the son of a [ __ ] dude okay
i thought those said this was over can't
you see that you son of a [ __ ]
just let me check out my groceries wow
[ __ ] you i'm trying to help you
[ __ ]
i mean you know wow this is you gotta
ask jesus christ i don't
no i'm not [ __ ] you [ __ ]
accuse her get the [ __ ] out of here you
[ __ ] accuser um you [ __ ]
accuser get the [ __ ] out of here wow you
[ __ ] chris farley in the
folger's commercial
chris farrell's commercial dude
like
what if i told you it wasn't your
regular coffee and it's [ __ ] folgers
you [ __ ] accuser
oh you want your [ __ ] pushed in
user of the [ __ ] brethren you
[ __ ]
yes ma'am oh and then the lady excuse me
yes ma'am
i'm pissed because you won't really come
i'm pissed because you won't repent
oh dude she's in the kids section of a
[ __ ] uh
ross dress for less
i just want to get some groceries and go
home
no prisoners dude okay so just because
his religious views don't uh match with
you uh doesn't give you the right to i
don't care
i don't care he's going to hell and you
are too [ __ ]
oh
you're gonna be down there [ __ ] with
them
screaming in holy [ __ ] tears so dude
[ __ ] fire and brimstone
what's brimstone by the way everyone
always says it you know
so dude
so dutiful hey [ __ ]
dude i'm trying to save your life
[ __ ]
wow unbelievable acholo the way she's
talking [ __ ] i'm just trying to help
you hey poker sorry but i don't need
your help
yes you do [ __ ] wow such a chill
you do you do need my help sir dude so
cholo uh a [ __ ] eat
[Laughter]
a [ __ ] repent dog hey [ __ ]
a [ __ ] repent dog
just
[ __ ] in target just so annoying
[Laughter]
a [ __ ]
[ __ ] pin hey he's going to hell
that's why he's going to hell that's why
youtube [ __ ]
where the [ __ ] where the where does
where the toilet paper so hey hey hey
wife get that [ __ ] a [ __ ] you're going
my wife ain't going to hell repent [ __ ]
see she just did it ay get grab the
kleenex and then also get the ring pops
a
[ __ ]
you got that bread
unbelievable you see that you son of a
[ __ ]
so uh like the way she's like trying to
be nice but also adding swear words just
don't mix you know i'm trying to help
you don't you see that you son of a
[ __ ]
just let me check out my groceries
i mean the fact that that comes after
that if you're just listening to it hey
[ __ ] a [ __ ] [ __ ] hey
[ __ ] hey [ __ ] i'm just trying
to help you can't you see that you son
of a [ __ ]
man will you just let me check out my
groceries like
dude oh sorry dog
that's my bee
hey dog
repaint dog
143 dog
or whatever the [ __ ] man
don't you know i'm [ __ ] crazy dog
people are insane
wow out of breath um
[Music]
crazy
[Music]